it's almost Christmas and I have noticed
that you have been very good this year
your name is on my place it must here
and the North Pole my else and working
hard dog has explosive diarrhea all over
the car she also got a pretty sharp fish
I would live it to me though be forget
to put the handbrake on turn the car
rolls aware see a monkey steals a purse
I reckon I know what happens I same here
I reckon I know where that is
yeah I reckon I think Cape sounds yeah
on the front this happens to my dad my
dad got out the car yeah with my mom and
my brother in Cape zone my mum got out
and then Boone's a baboon got in the
front seat of the car me dad froze as
this gorilla was growing not gorilla
baboon
gorilla that has me dad and we're going
to me mom's person me dad frozen would
have moved so I'm going see a monkey own
everybody's I'm gonna go see as well
they're gonna see a loner [ __ ] all over
a car only AC comes no that's that's
nice to see you know that's from Santa
Claus is it it's nice to see a child
born in the latter my kids we was in
Dubai for a while we came on for the
summer I've lots of coverage as
Christmas Day oh are you still kids a
letter you're so busy telling your
riveting story having
beautiful it's about winning there we go
hey the kid called Santa a bastard why
do I have to read that out me the kid
posed himself in excitement of the
letter so fired on a Connor I don't want
to see Ivory's see the kid angrily rips
up the letter that Santa is called
a bastard Eureka yes so why would the
kid call him the bastard
maybe he is questioning his parenting I
was born out of wedlock
I think Georgie's got a bit of a nasty
streak in in this kid like itself
kylie is gonna rip the letter or he's
from Bolton sure book him on the couch
there they've even got him on the end of
that get him on the air you know what
he's like enough there I'm going see I
thought one over I'm gonna I'm gonna go
he's posed himself oh all different come
on see president Hutton here we go
loving this
he's looking angry it's almost Christmas
and I have no estate you have been very
good this year your name is on my place
it must here and none of my else and
working hard soil of him so all the
dressing the ball isn't he
lat hits an unfortunate bird with the
ball that was a bee lad loses control of
his club and hits his friend across the
face that would be funny
ish see lad pulls off titter and
incredible under the leg trickshot
seriously I think one of our flying
friends yeah I do bird I go B this
laughs here's gonna get it in the
wouldn't be funny because he his teeth
Mikado he's in a bird comes the bird oh
it's border tricky to climax Oh
[Applause]
international sportsman scandalous he
always performs on the stage scandalous
oh thank you very much that was what
happens next on lap Bible buying ice I'm
slick